So, let me help you recall the last quiz first things first. Before we show that
if we had negative 3, the entire quantity taken the 4th power, that was equal to
positive 81. The difference between that question and this question here, is the
lack of parenthesis in this problem. This time we need to think about order of
operations. I'm not going to do a super in depth review of this here, but we're
going to give you plenty of review problems to practice it, and we'll also keep
touching on it at different points throughout the course, since it's pretty
fundamental to doing algebra or any other kind of math. You may have heard some
sort of mnemonic device or acronym earlier to help you remember The order that
we do different mathematical operations when we're evaluating expressions. So I,
for example, learned PEMDAS. Now, each of these letters stands for a different
mathematical operator. The P, here, is for parentheses. The E, here, stands for
exponents. The M stands for multiplication. The D stands for division. The A is
for addition, and the last but not least, the S is for subtraction. So this can
serve as a guideline, to tell us what order we do all these different operations
in, when we're looking at some set of numbers and variables combined together
with these operators. So in the last question we did, for example, since the P
for parentheses comes before the E for exponents, we knew that the negative sign
needed to be applied to the three. Since it was inside the parethesis before,
before we took that number to an exponent. There are no parenthesis written out
here. So we really have, when we have a negative sign in front of a number,
remeber is negative 1 times that number. So negative 3 is actually equal to
negative 1 times 3. And we take this 3 to the 4th power. The 4 is only attached
to this 3 now because there are no parenthesis that surround the negative sign
as well. Since PEMDAS tells us that we evaluate exponenents before we multiply
we first need to figure out what 3 to 4t h equals before we can multiply that by
negative 1. So we know that 3 to the 4th is equal to 3 times itself 4 times. So
now I will just multiply all this out and we get negative 81, so you can see
that negative 3 to the 4th power gives us a completely different answer than the
whole quantity of negative 3 taking to the 4th power. Parenthesis make a huge
difference from using exponents so I say please don't forget to take advantage
of review exercises we give you. You want to make sure that things like order of
operations, that you've probably seen in previous courses, feel completely
comfortable for you. So, if you're having trouble at all with this, or just want
to make sure that you totally understand it, do a bunch of our practice
problems. This is going to help establish a really strong foundation for you as
we move forward in this course.